what's up chickadees I am back on tour
my solo is stopped for now because the
Impractical Jokers are back on our
national tour huge theater Arena tour
it's going on right this second all
tickets are on sale 40 or 50 cities are
on sale we're adding more just go to
impractical
jokerslive.com for all the cities to
take a look uh coming up off the top
right now we have uh Pittsburgh
Pennsylvania Camden New Jersey at the
freedom mortgage Pavilion that's a big
one down Jersey about Philly love to see
you guys two at the Wang in Boston then
we're going to Charleston and Charlotte
and Waterloo New York and then
Washington DC and the big weekend I want
to talk about is Niagara Falls into
Prudential Center in Newark New Jersey
uh then right up to Wallington
Connecticut and coming back down to play
the UBS arena in Long Island those are
all on sale right now plus more and
practicejokerslive.com and Impractical
Jokers season 10 is airing right now on
TruTV and TBS Thursday nights at 10
o'clock folks Joe DeRosa here from the
taste buds podcast I got live
performances and shows and all kinds of
things happening all over the place let
me start with a very special appearance
I'll be making here in New York City on
February 8th at New York City City
Winery my buddy cooge is doing an
evening with cousin friends I'll be
there with couge and some other folks a
little bit of a Roundtable discussion
about food and whatnot lots of laughs
what have you a little bit of a
different show but it's going to be fun
also here in New York City I'm doing my
residency of my new one-man show I Never
Promised You a Rose Garden next one of
those is February 14th the night for
lovers at the crane theater after that
we got one in March on the 22nd again at
the crane theater so if you're in New
York come on by for that and if you're
not New York I'm hitting the big open
road February 18th Vancouver British
Columbia for jfl's Festival Baton Rouge
on March 9th March 10th Lafayette March
11th New Orleans March 30th Amtrak
Michigan March 32 first Grand Rapids
Michigan April 1st Chicago Illinois and
more dates are being added as we speak
all of the dates I just added mentioned
on the road will be me performing the I
Never Promised You a Rose Garden Show
you can go to jodarosainfo.com for
tickets and info also don't forget about
Joey roses open seven days a week at 11
30 a.m every day sandwiches and booze
flowing and chewing all day long
joeyrosesnyc.com
[Music]
coming to the mic talking about the food
they hate talking about the food they
like two Fool's gonna fight but only one
food can be right taste buds man yeah
they're coming to the mic hey folks
welcome to
t-a-s-d-e buzz we're here with our
special guest Paul verzi and right
before we started rolling we this would
have been a great battle
Staten Island versus Long Island
you said you'd take Staten Island but I
gotta tell you the only three people I
know on Staten Island are Q
yeah and the pig to Stefano so right off
the bat yeah but we're not off to a
great start wait but the Stefano is not
from the Stefano's not from no he lives
there now and he loves it and calls
himself chose to go there he shows and
is he claiming it is he like claiming he
stops he loves it okay
two of my dearest friends two of my
dearest friends you and Peter from there
I I everybody I've met from Staten
Island has been has been great
I have family in Long Island so if
anybody hears this you know look they're
they're somewhat similar I'll tell you
that much but there's something about
Long Island dude that like they're just
in this way they're against it they like
they will like you said they'll mob
against you if one thing right you could
go on stage and say one two oh no no but
it's just like but they also will like I
was just out at Governors I had great
shows but when I would say that I was
from Philly they'd boo but then I would
[__] on them for booing and then they
would laugh at me [__] on them so
it's a fair play Staten Island I don't
know I've never done it I did a comedy
show Once in Staten Island and it was
the comedy show where I met Pete
Davidson he was 15 years old and uh I
wonder if it was mine he told me he
looked up to me thanks for remembering
Pete anyway uh put me in one of these
[__] shows uh no but uh there was my
first my Pete at the at the Looney Bin
I don't think and the shows weren't bad
but that was the only time I ever did a
yeah it's I almost had two comedy clubs
since I'm alive I think one was called
Grandpa's Comedy Club it was owned by
Grandpa from the uh no from the monsters
yes yes so wait Grandpa from the
monsters named it that yes right yeah
now Lewis owned it Al Lewis his face was
on the awning bro pretty cool I saw a
Dice Clay there that's wild Grandpa's
comedy yeah man that's been shut for I
want to say 20 years and then the Looney
Bin was at a bowling alley and I never I
never performed there but it was open
for a bit uh but I I don't know was it a
real comedy club or was it like a comedy
space
uh well look man there was caution tape
on the back wall of the stage just to
let everybody know that there was some
loony stuff going on
so who knows okay you know what I mean
but uh I would say yeah it was probably
a comedy club if that's if I remember I
went I remember my first manager Tony
Camacho right I'm sure you've heard it
no Tony well and and I'm like I'm like a
couple years in this is why I might have
said this on another pocket this is
[__] so true hilarious I Get There He
Go Tony goes I got you gig it's at a
restaurant in Staten Island they're
gonna give you 150. and I got it he goes
but it's a Friday so you're working so
I'm like I'm like all right you know so
I go there dude and it's like an open
floor it almost looked like a dime it
was like a diner for sure do you
remember the name of the place I don't
remember the name of the place and I got
there first and early because I'm you
know it's the weekend and I know my
drive is going to be long and the owner
comes up and the owner just goes he goes
look guy I didn't want to do this
first thing he says he goes if it was me
I would have gotten local kids to bring
their friends and fill the place but I
talked to your manager he said he's
going to send a couple of pros and I
that's the first thing he says then he
goes another thing dude I swear to God
he goes there's no mic he goes but no no
I swear to God he goes he goes like this
he goes but
three blocks down is a Radio Shack I'm
not paying for it
but if you want to go get it and pick
you know we could set it up I'm not
paying for it I didn't want to do this I
wanted to get local amazing so now me
I'm going I would rather not do it
two comedians other comedians come in
and do they were like I need to do the
work I need the work we're going to do
it I'm standing in the middle of a
restaurant I never forget there was a
father and son eating chicken parm and
they were looking up at a at a TV video
of a game on yeah and they and I go you
guys gonna turn he goes no just go and
do it dude and I remember standing there
the TV's rough my grandmother I'm like
yeah so my grandmother wants me to and
they're just like looking around me at
the TV it was an absolute [__] dude I
did I did so many so many of those types
of gig we all did starting out and like
it's it it was so is amazing to me it's
like that the attitude of that guy yes
because that was always the attitude of
the guy at the place that was like that
was like I didn't want to do this well
then why'd you do it right this wasn't
my manager's idea to have a show here
right you were looking to have a show
and now you're acting like I'm some kind
of Burden you know what I mean like the
amount of shows I did in bars on Monday
nights where they wouldn't turn the TVs
off and say why are you doing this just
don't have the show right like what is
the it's like are you being defiant to
like prove that it's not conducive so
you can go back and say see I told you
it's like yeah why don't you make it the
best for everybody there um two of my
biggest bombs ever had TVs involved
actually sure there's a place in L.A Joe
maybe you know what it's called
something Lodge it's a very hip bar and
a hip town oh a Bigfoot Lodge Bigfoot
Lodge they shoot comedy shows in the
back I lived a block from it okay yeah
yes as a matter of fact I might have
done it way back in the day when you had
your show it very well could have so I
did this show it's a big film Josh
androsky was it his showroom glasses
yeah yeah I don't know so I did the show
at the Bigfoot Lodge we go in the back
the places like has like 20 people in a
total it's a big place I'd say 15 of
them are at the front bar and there's
either yes TVs on or the rated music
whatever yeah you're in the back four
people came and sat in the back you're
on a on a makeshift little corner with a
with a mic yeah I start talking to the
four people I mean you can't even and
there's a couple of comics in the
background I think Ramon Rivas was with
me and uh everything's just bombing and
and and and and you hearing
conversations from the bar you're
hearing the television and conversations
from the bar dude that was like and I
was like that was years and years ago
but I remember people like some someone
came to see me there you know when
someone from like that you know is like
oh we're coming to the show
um
no don't come to the show do I'm doing a
12-minute spot on Wednesday right and
they come anyway and it's like yeah I
can't bend my set to you I gotta try
this new [__] and they come and they see
you and then it's like I can't even talk
to you I gotta run the next time they
see you it was like not a good show and
they're like you you did good you did
nice
no I tell people now I tell people
they're like hey you're gonna be and I'm
like look I'm working on new jokes and
I'm gonna be up there for 12 15 minutes
I'm gonna be headlining right Gotham in
a couple minutes come to that this Foot
Lodge right so everyone's over there
talking they don't stop talking you hear
them just as loud as my mic there's
three comics in the back left there's
two people here and two people like four
feet in front of me only and before I
start the lady in front of me goes we're
in town on vacation we're from wherever
the [__] she said like you know she's
like We're from it was somewhere far
away right and she's like and we saw
that you were here we thought we'd make
a night of it right before I go on and
she's two of the four people there
I bombed so bad I bomb so bad that
afterwards I went up to the bar to get
like a water and I was like trying to
hide myself because even the people that
are at the bar they hear me too but
they're still talking no one's laughing
I was like that's the one where you
start to swear yeah had that flops went
and then I was at the bar and they went
to go talk to me and I went oh you know
what I just gotta take this I faked the
call went out gotten got a newborn
didn't come back in I was so I was like
I can't walk back in there I bomb so
hard I can't even face the other Escape
the Escape after a bomb is one of the
where you just closed the car door wow
all right I beat the call and I was like
I had that feeling in the middle
of me like oh I was so embarrassed as
the car speeds away you feel like you're
leaving the feeling the further away you
get from it I got hired to do it I got
hired to do a house party in Seattle
City for a family reunion they hired me
it was like two years in that just gave
me anxiety of saying that dude I was in
the living room yeah they were all
sitting in the living room they set it
up to like a show they set up like rows
of chairs they cleared out the furniture
and everything it's rich [__] down in
Seattle City uh and um
I was doing I was doing well actually I
was doing well I had a hot I just hot
chick that I met at Hooters waitress was
with me it was like our first date like
I was like I was like King [__] wait
your first date with the [__] Hooters
waitress met me in Sea Isle City yeah
yeah
and I felt like the [__] man and I'm
I'm popped in front of us to a family
reunion I'm I'm on stage show at Hooters
yeah well because they paid me yeah I
know they paid me like they actually
paid me like it was like 300 bucks or
something like first year or two I was
like wow I'm doing a private all right
that's what I thought yeah yeah how much
day at stage I'm in the I'm by the bay
windows
and I was doing well honestly it was
going well like they were into it and
stuff and I'm doing crowd work and stuff
and I had a bit at the time about why I
didn't want to have kids
uh and I said to this and I said it I
set it up in there by talking to one of
the guys that was just this older guy
that was sitting in the front I go you
got kids buddy and goes yeah and I go uh
you know I don't want to have kids you
know I'm afraid what if I have a kid I
don't like it right and that was the
setup for the joke this [__] kid who
was like 20 21 jumps up out of the back
of the room and he goes you mother
that's my father you [__] sucker what
I swear to god dude what was he upset
about and all you said was I don't know
it was his because I was talking to his
father and I said I'm afraid what if I
had a kid and I didn't like it this kid
took it personally who was his son they
escorted the kid out
they go we're really sorry uh he's
always a problem at these things exactly
that's a really reunion at events and
the thing he's mad about has to do with
families in advance they said he's
always gets drunk and he's a problem did
Dad apologize to me and then I bombed
for the remaining 30 minutes of my set
and then I had to there's no longer walk
dude than walking from the front of
somebody's living room through the
family that you just bombed in front of
and then they walked me into the kitchen
and then they were like we're so sorry
we're so sorry can we get you something
[Laughter]
after you said I don't know if it's
gonna go well the kids started yelling
like see that's why dude I was so I want
you my point exactly it's so funny yeah
like it's like now if that happened now
you'd be like oh yeah you know fun with
it you'd make fun of it they dragged the
kid out you'd make jokes about that
shocking fit at the time a year to it
you're like what the [__] is going on
yeah do you like you remember being like
new new and you're going if somebody
yells out and starts heckling and
screaming like if someone goes hey [__]
it like now you could be like what'd you
say wait no no and then just go because
we're we're welcome no we're experienced
did you used to welcome I used to be so
nervous I was gonna somebody's gonna
yell something I used to get I this is I
swear to God I used to get nerves
if I was killing I'd get nerves because
I'd be like well I I can only [__] this
up oh you would start watching
yeah I can only [__] this up that makes
sense I want this to end right now yes
the only person who walk on stage at the
59th minute still be worried that could
all go very wrong I don't feel that way
the lottery and he's like yeah people
are going to ask you I don't know things
are gonna go bad I I don't I haven't
felt that way in a very very long time
but there was a period where I did feel
like that on stage and I swear to God I
told my therapist that at the time and
she goes I don't even know what to say
she's like it's not in the books I I
studied I don't know you know you know
who's a an amazing like example of when
things are going good on stage they
don't like it was de Paulo dude I would
see Nick depaolo at the stand the first
stand when he would come down and he
would start killing and things were
going good and it was almost like he's
like nah now I I literally watched him
like I was like oh this is not gonna get
awkward like this is and he and he
couldn't he he would just look for
something
him and Patrice I saw go at people in
the audience in ways that I've never
seen and it would make me laugh so
[__] hard the it would it would just
the the vehement
them it was just like oh my God man it
made me laugh so [__] hard that's I
saw the Apollo say to a guy once at the
stand he goes he goes yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah because you think you had
[__] don't you yeah well I can kick your
[__] ass because I do Coke
dude I saw him one time just look and go
why do I come to this shitty City dude
he he went from like killing to just
looked around and like said something
that I think you know he did a depollo
joke by the way Nick was the one of the
only people that I could have I saw that
everybody in the room just goes oh no
like that and then the next thing get an
ovation he was one of the few that could
do it but then he would just go why do I
come to this shitty City and would just
like would like lay into the City and
then it would get quiet after a good set
and he like liked it he was Unreal dude
oh so funny
I love telling bomb stories I can never
get old to me but you know we were
talking about this the other day some
Comics like when they watch somebody
bomb I don't and I was actually like I'm
talking about when you see somebody up
there I'm not talking about a guy that
we like that's what we were talking
about when it's a guy that you know is
funny and he's working stuff out and it
doesn't work that's kind of funny right
like that's like oh you're like my buddy
my buddy's up there he's he's trying to
show sure but when you see when I see
somebody when I see somebody straight up
like there's nothing and they're like
trying I I want to walk I don't like
seeing the full-on yeah like a real
somebody's dreams getting [__] like
I'll watch it for a second and then I'm
like I can't
one of the things we do a lot in my
house
and we literally are searching scouring
the internet for bombs and we just watch
it like we're watching a [__] HBO
show oh my God it's my favorite dude
watching it watching it go sideways I
[__] love it when it ends up with
like someone like a guy one guy did you
shoot up bomb it was like at like a
restaurant where the old guys giving guy
[__] and it's like oh it's like a mic
and the old guy's like a regular for
like 20 years and everybody and he's
cursing at the guy and he's cursing at
the guy and the guy even knows his name
he's like Philip he's like don't do it
again Phillip and he goes to shut the
[__] up Philip I'm trying to do my show
and then whatever whatever guy's name is
and then Philip charges him he goes
don't judge me don't charge me Phillip
and he kicks him right in the [__] oh
yes yes
I told him not to charge me and then
everybody in the crowd's going oh why'd
you do that they looked like they were
in a bowling alley
yes I remember seeing that going like
why would you do stand up there oh my
god dude like when it ends up like that
too like I got the comic sticking an old
man in the chest my two favorite comedy
types of Comedy to watch and it's often
with you yeah uh
somebody the the dream crushing bomb
like you just talked about like where
it's just it's everything is going wrong
you're getting Deuce chills I mean it's
just my favorite and then rivaled only
by somebody crushing with absolute
horseshit where it makes me see red
where I see I see red because it makes
me so mad but they're my favorite types
of Comedy to watch both of those things
fuel me in a way like that you're
enraged but would you you like to watch
The Comedy gets me it gets gets me going
but then something gonna come along like
Nick Kroll's latest special and I'll
watch oh I didn't see it I watched 10
minutes of it I go this is really good
all right and then I turn it up
yeah you like clean your palette with a
decent thing
this is very good good stuff Nick all
right anyway let's get back to the who's
bombing it's just more fun to watch man
yeah like I had a NYU NYU car hiring us
for a gig one time we went and it was it
was for the students and it was during
the base it was the
2003 the Yankees were in the playoffs
right versus like Philly or something
like that I'm sorry to play off the uh
the World Series no that was 2009. 2009.
they beat the field yeah in 2009. no
what's the one before that oh they
weren't there by anyway maybe it was
playoffs and um
it was also finals or or whatever there
was some type of big test I don't know
what and the place was like in the
basement of the dorms and it was like
basically like a almost like a cafeteria
and it was you know an old New York
buildings they you can't control the
heat right the winter the heat's on yeah
it was the worst it was like 110 degrees
and the doors like it had a it was like
a railroad so it like there was when you
came in the next room and then you saw
the next room and you saw the next room
so like the room could have held 200
people easy Maybe
maybe 15 came they were all spread out
and they all brought their textbooks and
so they were they were watching while
they were like doing their homework and
in the Next Room oh the [__] Yankee
playoffs wrong oh no this was when I was
I mean this was like
probably the year I would say maybe 2003
2002 something like that
um
I remember I'm sweating already just
from the heat nothing's Landing they're
looking down in their books right and
then I literally heard [__] Joe bucko
ground Bowl the cheater you just heard
it in the room you heard the [__]
play-by-play there and I started
sweating so much and I remember nothing
it was almost like the beaches in
Normandy the only thing I remember was
that one time I did an impression of a
chicken because I was I don't know why I
did it I was like I don't know why I did
it but I was like that's how bad it was
that I ended up clocking it
I was I was literally I literally was
listening to the playoff game oh God
yeah it was bad man and then we
apologize I apologized they gave me they
gave me 550 and that we I thought you
were like hey I was like listen I'm
really sorry our shows are not normally
like this and then we had a big fight
with us because we left and my buddy's
like don't ever apologize for a show I'm
like that was an apology
oh my God that's amazing man that's so
great that's amazing hey guys
hey guys maybe next time
guys I don't know what happened either
hey let's go Yanks huh
yeah that's brutal man there wasn't a
[__] laugh not even a Pity laugh I
would I wish I could have seen it yeah
look because that's that's the best
that's better than the other two things
I already mentioned the best is seeing
your friend who you know is funny Bob no
why should a friend go out on his ass oh
it's so funny it's funny the material
Keith Robinson is the best like Keith
Keith because Keith will be like you
[__] stunk
I saw your bomb last night nah they
hated you and then if he bombs he'll be
like God damn it I deserved everything
how they handed me my chops I'm gonna
close my eyes do Keith Robin talking to
Bobby Kelly go ahead no no I'll be I'll
be Florentine okay no
ask me as Keith if I saw the Super Bowl
Halftime hey stupid you see the Super
Bowl halftime show
yeah nobody wants to hear Madonna at
halftime
that's on candy yeah
it's [__] brutal nobody cares Like a
Virgin give me a brain
folks let's talk about Bessie one of our
great sponsors uh vesi were they were
kind enough to send me some shoes and I
I finally got to try these things out
and I gotta tell you they are fantastic
all-weather shoes now in New York what
does that mean where I live it means
they're good for the winter uh they're
good for the rain uh in particular uh
and I like
that this company vesi is doing this the
first time I put these shoes on I
immediately noticed how comfortable they
were uh how easy they were to get on and
off which I know might sound like a a
sort of trivial point but it's not I'm
telling you uh when you have all weather
shoes uh we'll call them uh and you a
lot of the time like you know for
instance my other shoes that I wear out
in the snow or rain are boots it's a
it's a process they're heavy boots you
got to get your foot in they lace all
the way up it's a lot the fact that
vessey has me and also too they're not
the most comfortable thing they're not
terrible but they're not the most
comfortable the fact that vessey made
basically a shoe that is all the
features of a rubber boot but it's built
into a sneaker
that's super comfortable 100 waterproof
uh not water resistant waterproof uh and
you can slip these things on and off
very easily I mean I I think it's
awesome uh they're warm but they're
light they're much lighter than boots
that's for certain they have a lugged uh
rubber outsole that gives you extra grip
in in wet conditions which again I
really like because some of the boots I
have uh actually it gets slippery when
it's wet outside which is not fun yes I
have fallen enjoy that visual anyway
these things are made from dime attacks
uh which is a super soft knit material
that keeps your feet warm in the cold uh
but it also can keep them cool in the
warmer months so you can wear these year
round
um
and it doesn't feel like it should be
waterproof but it is uh it's comfortable
it's durable it's breathable how
comfortable again sneaker comfortable
with a boots protection it's really
great Bessie are my go-to shoes by the
door go check them out for yourself
here's the link vesi.com taste buds and
uh you're gonna go buy your own pair of
Essie shoes there again go go to
again check them out vessey that's
v-e-s-s-i.com tastebuds
and go buy yourself a pair of these
again it's vessi
v-e-s-s-i.com taste buds you're gonna
get 15 off a pair go and do it now
composting is an interesting process
it's a useful process it's it's helpful
not just to you but to the environment
and uh to to there are many there are
many reasons that composting is helpful
and I got to tell you if you are compact
on Space composting is a tough thing to
do and it was been a tough thing for me
to do an impossible thing for me to do
is I live in New York City I don't have
a composting bin for me I actually I I
do want to do more things that are
better for the environment I feel guilty
I don't use plastic bottles but like I'm
looking for something else to have that
wow like that Eco guilt kind of thing
loamy is here to help yeah loamy is a
countertop composting product you take
your compostable materials you put them
into the thing and it quietly over a
short period of time meaning under four
hours turns that stuff into dirt into
usable soil uh it's great well that's
wild with the push of a button it turns
it from that into into dirt that's it
and I gotta tell you too uh if you want
to look at this from a selfish
standpoint it's saving you garbage bags
it's saving you garbage can space and
saving you Trips Trips the fudging trips
[Laughter]
yo dude my garbage in my house is like a
standard size garbage it fills up in a
regular day like two three times if I
have company I'm running to throw the
garbage out three four five times yeah
this does it in under four hours there's
no smell and it's quiet when it does it
yeah and you know believe it or not as
as somebody that lives in New York uh
and I'm complaining about space and not
having a yard and all this stuff I can't
actually find uses for some soil you
know I can grow uh herbs okay I have a
little Terrace that I could grow some
things on I've had an aero Garden in the
past uh you know the soil is more useful
even if you end up just throwing the
soil away who cares it doesn't smell but
it's still better forever the garbage
isn't going to landfills it's not
producing methane you turn waste into
nutrient Rich dirt that you could use
for your plants it's just better that's
it it's just better right so head to
loamy.com that's lomi.com taste buds use
the promo code taste buds you're going
to get fifty dollars is off your loamy
that's a lot off that's great
lomi.com tastebuds use the promo code
taste buds for fifty dollars off today
food waste is gross let loamy save you a
cold trip out to the garbage can one
last thing I will say it's fun to use
because they sent them to us and it is
actually fun to put all the scraps in
there and then fun to see it turn into
there so it's actually cool
spots
yeah Florentine was just that I told
Patrick I was like hey man there you
know book me like if Florentine going
because he booked me for like you know
you'll do like four and a night three in
a night you have to stay you gotta eat
dinner and I saw Florence I saw
Florentine on the list and I go thanks
for so Florentine watches and any kind
of edgy thing yeah that was great yeah
yeah yeah
looked like he was worried about a
writing packet on the table Yeah Yeah
I was saying you were met like that I
was saying that the crowd must have
really bothered you for like for your
for that to be your answer it got me
yeah the first show
was great and the second show they were
laughing but they weren't
I get the thing that gets me with an
audience is I don't I I ask I don't like
when they're not connecting when they're
not tuned in and I said to them
I did a joke and I was like and they
were being weirdly quiet I go you know
what I mean and and one person went no
and I was just like this isn't like
I'm like this isn't it wasn't heavy
concept [__] it was like yeah you're
just not seeing whatever you thought
this was going to be yes and it's
annoying me now and I showed my own ass
by getting aggravated about it but then
a lot of times for me
that turns into like it ends up like
kind of working I guess because
you know I get frustrated and I and then
I end up trying to make that funny and
then and then that works and then
whatever so like that's what I gotta go
out does that make sense yeah I have to
go out in a different way unfortunately
because people know me or they think
they do and they know my personality and
I'm very nice yeah so if I if something
happens like that and I go at them like
that everyone's like oh like they won't
laugh at it they're almost like oh wow
he's mad or always being a dick no they
people like when I do that but it's
actually you're right well this weekend
in Long Island there were there were
tons of taste buds shout outs by the way
thank you to everybody that came out to
Levittown and thank you to everybody who
came up to the Vulcan in Austin what a
great two weekends of shows thank you
everybody yeah but but I'm going to
Austin and Long Island practical
jokerslive.com UBS we need you guys
there go ahead
you guys but the second show in
Levittown on Saturday
[Laughter]
uh the second show in Long Island in
Levittown uh there were a couple people
there was a lady in the front row
that was just having a full conversation
oh yeah so she was like an older woman
and she wasn't trying to be rude but she
was just talking to her friend something
I said where they were like oh that's
like and they started talking and then
eventually I go have a full [__]
conversation and like you could see that
I like legit was annoyed yeah and I go
Jesus [__] Christ can anybody leave
the [__] house anymore and I started
kind of side ranting about that and they
were cheering and [__] because I was
like yeah they because you're like
you're saying they're like oh he's gonna
do the things
people talking I had to go at it like
with kindness and make it like I have to
like be like crafty about it like jail
you big Jay's always like don't ever go
at him like go at him you know like go
at them don't go don't make it
contentious right he's like that's his
big advice like when he because he's you
know does a lot of crowd yeah but I have
to be I'll try to turn it on them but
not for me I'll be like you know
everyone in here hears you not just me
right and everyone in here paid to be
here for a show now
you could do whatever you want I think
you seem great right but everybody in
here right now hates your [__] guts
and everyone starts cheering right now
you really like what but what you how no
I hate it what you're really more Angry
than that I hate it you hate it but
because yeah see that's I hate the drunk
that thinks they're helping too not not
just a solid conversation but the one
that's like yes yes because yes me too
so it's like we just had that I had that
at the stand and I knew she was doing it
to everybody and then finally I just I
just addressed I go I know you keep
saying that we all that's why we and
then she just and the boyfriend just
went like this I do have a question for
Sal do you ever have a fantasy of going
just full Bob Saget one night
you're seen clean but you get to go
fulfilled yeah I I when I when I first
first thought I had more more stuff like
that and I just as I went on I'm like
because you know sometimes I'll just
write the joke that comes to mind and
then it's not really like in the voice
that I would do it and I'll do it for a
while it'll get less and stuff but then
I'm like I don't really want to do that
material so then I would just like kind
of retire I will tell you this dude
right the same way not to put too fine a
point on anything but the same way in
which you have to
find this weird balance between I don't
do sex stuff like I don't gratuitously
curse if I you know the um but those
what I'd love to watch you guys uh
switch sets for a night
oh that's so funny that'd be a fun show
it's like Comics just change personality
we should do a we should do a Purdue
show oh my God yeah we get comics and it
just Comics just like you get four
comics and everybody switches to
personality I think that might be a show
somebody does already where you have to
do the other person's but I don't know
okay but but I would do it yeah I would
do it but but real quick real quick
though the the way you have to find the
balance with yourself where you said you
hate it but then you say it in a certain
way I'm doing the same thing even though
it seems like oh but you're you get to
be you because you're like you you
you're an outbursty guy and whatever
I I trust me it's the same thing because
there was a part of me and there still
is a part of me that goes I'll burn this
whole [__] Showdown right now right
you know what I mean like I'm so mad
I'll ruin it yeah and I had to learn how
to not do that I had to learn how to be
like no dude if you do this much anger
it's funny
and you're still getting out of your
system and moving on and handling it
sure if you do this much now now the
person because the lady that I got mad
about at Governors she stopped talking
and listening had a great time
immediately right yeah like because I
learned that there was a way that I
could be angry where it was still
weirdly funny but friendly yes did the
club do anything for that with that lady
or no today like at least I nipped that
one in the bud quickly but there were
two other people on Friday that they
that they ejected with with haste which
was nice the uh the uh Palm Beach West
Palm Improv yeah last year at some point
and uh you know you know the room right
yeah and the tables are right the small
stages right there front right some
white blonde girl with another girl she
was they were two at the table there was
two behind them they weren't together
she's talking she's talking she's
drinking she she's swaying in her chair
and everything I go to her
I address it make a whole bunch of jokes
get some last move away she doesn't stop
I go back to her she doesn't stop and
now I'm like saying like all right I've
made jokes I've been playful with her I
made them laugh at the situation I kind
of did my job she's still going I'm like
waiting for the club to say something
and I don't want to be the guy at my
shows to be like listen one more and
you're out or take her out I don't want
to really do that I think I hope for the
club would do that right so she keeps
going next thing I know I'm telling a
joke I turn around she's on stage she's
literally on the stage and I look at her
and I go this is insane that that club
by the way okay how about this before I
went on stage a woman just came into the
green room and with her camera on video
and walked in and just started a video
of me and said say hello to my my my
whatever my my aunt my cousin my son I
was like oh do you work for the club and
she's like no she was drunk I'm like you
have to get out of here this is the
Green Room like this isn't right it was
during covet it was not the club has
been watching The Green Room no the guy
who was at the door stepped away and
apologized but she just walked right in
then later she was heckling me I'm like
are you the [__] woman that came out
of the way why is the club why is the
audience able to even see the Green Room
like what the [__] is that you know what
I mean yeah the Green Room at the West
Palm because it's literally as they're
filing as they're filing into the
showroom it's right there so if the
door's not closed
this [__] job is so low I mean it's
just I have a joke in my ACT where I go
real I make fun of make fun of real
estate agents like a real estate that is
the last stop before porn on the on the
career train right and I go and then it
goes real estate porn stand-up comedy
this is the [__] lowest for that
reason for [__] like that where it's
just like wow we're treating somebody
gets on stage the green room's not
protected the green room's in plain
sight the the it's unfucking believable
to me man like like and like look you're
clearly the most famous guy in the room
you know what I mean but take that off
the table take it but but I'm saying I'm
saying take your I'm not saying to you
like I know what you mean but like take
that off the table just as professional
it's like it's not okay if you're just
some regular guy who does comedy and you
offend somebody yeah they should not be
able to figure out how how to get to you
right after the show on the stage I turn
around this was before the show but I
know but you know what I'm saying so
yeah I turn around she's on the stage
and I'm like this is insane so I I say a
couple days I'm like security like they
they come and they walk and they stand
right at the bottom stage and they're
watching her watching me and I'm just
looking at him
so I'm like you have to go back down the
steps now so she goes back down the
steps she's standing there's a brick
wall right there she's standing there
and she's still talking and I'm trying
to do my set and then all of a sudden
she quiet and they talked to her she
quieted down and all of a sudden she
lost her balance and went back trip hit
the brick wall okay knocked over a
bucket that had beers on it on the table
okay everyone's like oh my God I'm like
all right they put they don't inject her
they put her back in her seat okay they
put her back in the seat waitress comes
over can we get you something
dude
five minutes later five minutes later
I'm I'm doing this that still and I look
over and this is her in her seat in the
front row her foot touching the stage
she's like
oh yeah yeah oh that's the worst
passed out mouth open for the rest of
the show they didn't even tell her to
leave they didn't take her out that's
great that's great that's so funny
that's so funny guy a guy came up to me
at the at the meet and greet uh on
Saturday and he goes dude the rose I
don't know if you remember me I've been
to your Barb I got engaged to my girl it
I forget what he said the engagement how
but it doesn't matter he was a very nice
kid
yeah yeah could you come out with a girl
and he goes yeah she's up she's passed
out in the car
and I go she is and he goes yeah she
started fading toward the end I was like
God bless her I didn't even notice he
goes yeah I brought her outside she was
like go in and say hi like go go through
the I was like that's a Class Act
actually it got bad yeah quietly let's
get you outside and then I'm gonna go
back and do the meet and greet well
that's what happened at the stand where
this woman was doing that overly
agreeing yeah I was like yeah I saw this
show yes yes and she kept doing it so
finally she gets shut down and the guy's
going oh and like his his head is in his
hands but it's like dude you know like
like what that guy did is what you're
supposed to do where it's like look we
paid money like either let's get you out
of here you know the guys always go
sorry dude I'm sorry but then let's her
yeah lets her do shots and drinks it's
like don't say sorry get her the [__]
out of here like a guy on Friday night
at Governor's was drunk and talking I
don't even think he was mad I don't you
think he was talking about me or to me
he was just talking yeah like he was
just [__] cocked this kid this kid
he's 50 years old yeah you know and
James the owner
James the owner came over and was like
you know talk to him and was like look
dude come on
and James told me this after the fact
because they did eject him and it was a
thing dude and then these other two guys
that were drunk started when the guy was
getting ejected started saying to the
[__] guy like get the [__] out you
can't handle your [__] liquor man no
and now the crowd is getting mad at both
of them the guy that's defending me the
guy that's gonna get I'm like oh my gosh
that's all just [__] yeah you know
I love those fans though the defending
fans it was awesome yeah it was it was
awesome I had one guy but but real quick
though yeah this is what James told me
this is where people are at mentally he
goes he goes Joe he goes I tell the guy
I go you got to shut the [__] up man
there's a show going on right and he
goes so he stops talking he goes the guy
starts humming
because he's like I can't talk so I'm
gonna sit here and hum oh yeah so that's
just a dick this is like what we're
dealing with yeah we we are hey we are
scum yeah
her birthday's here it's like it's like
nobody yeah nobody cares it happened in
Long Island but I bet you was from
Staten I think it was the meeting of two
months
they drove over
it was the culmination of the two
islands
folks let's talk about Noom uh noom's
been a long time sponsor of the show and
I'm happy they are I actually was in the
uh airport the other day and I saw the
new book
at the airport bookstore and I was
really I was like excited I was like man
I've known about noon for a long time
and that's right and I know they just
put this book out and look at this man
that's pretty cool that like they're in
the airport now bookstore you know but
not name-dropping but this is true uh
this week we wrapped on season 10 of
jokers and the last guest of this season
was Joey Fatone who is who hosts our
other show and everything was on and I
hadn't seen him in some time I swear to
God and I was like dude you lost weight
he's like I've been using Noom I'm not
joking I wouldn't put that out there on
his behalf if he wasn't so it it's it's
out there and people are using it that I
know and it's actually working now we've
known about it for a while because what
it's not a fad diet it's nothing like
that it's just your eating habit it
changes your eating habits it changes
the relationship you have with food how
you think about food how you consume
food yeah it's amazing it's a lifestyle
change it's not a diet I I think it's
great I I love that they're tying
psychology to eating uh and and what's
going on up here to what's going on in
here and why you're putting stuff in
here
it's psychology to help you understand
your eating habits it's awesome
it's like a it's like a it's like a
weight loss coach in your pocket you
know it's it's something that's there to
help you get you know the check-ins and
the the quizzes and I'll tell you this
because it's we get copy to read and we
use our personal experience combined
with the copy but right here it says do
you eat because you're bored I
absolutely do that or you can't pass a
food when it's free like legit like
those are two things I do all the time
don't stress Newman can help you break
the cycle and change your habits for
good okay so stay focused with what's
important to you with new weights
psychology-based approach sign up for
your trial today at noon.com tastebud
singular that's n-o-o-m.com tastebud
sign up for your trial today and as I
mentioned check out noom's first ever
book the new mindset possibly at an
airport near you and it's a deep dive
into the psychology of behavior change
available to buy now wherever people
that walk down the center aisles if
we're they walk down the middle of the
show walk down the center I'll wear
white walk right up to the stage yeah
and just start talking to us yeah yeah
they're just what are you doing yeah
it's just not even drunk yeah or they
just go hand us like a bag I'm like
thank you for this but like so good I
know I will say Italian audience members
I'm not trying listen I'm not trying to
be biased on my mother's 100 quick I'm
50 Greek Italian audience members are
some of the funniest because when it
starts to get real they're like I was in
I was in Arizona and four Dudes just
like and they were like you know big
beard but fans genuine Fair version we
love you right but then they start they
were doing shots they start so like the
last 20 they're like going over the bill
really loud disruptive and I did it a
couple times and two of them are like
sorry then the one guy goes first what
the [__] I'm trying to and it turned and
all of it says what the [__] no [__]
like it started to be like that and this
table of Italian Guys Paulie don't worry
about it we got you
don't worry about it no matter what
happens this week we got you and then
now they start looking and it's this
whole thing but it was so funny because
it just went from a comedy show to
Italian dudes being like if this goes
down
Italians when Italians love you last
thing so Stacy Stacy and I go to this
Christmas party for her new job like so
her company got bought right and all
this new company merged in and she goes
they're all doing this big party Long
Island swear to God right we're driving
out to the shore and Joe I'm driving out
to the shore I'm talking two hours for a
Christmas party midweek we got a
babysitter Stacy's like oh we're just
gonna go meet these people so I get
there and uh the special was out so a
bunch of people you know knew watch the
special stuff so this Italian guy walks
over like he goes hey Stacy how you
doing I'm glad I'm glad to come I swear
to God not just I'm not making stuff for
the show he goes stay you know I don't
glad things merged You're great and he
just walks over I swear to God I never
met the guy I'm just gonna he brought up
the murderer
like he's doing all that stuff right and
he just walks over and he goes I guess I
swear to God I'm just trying to get out
of here I'm trying to get out we're
about to leave and he goes Paul verzi
goes how you doing he goes he goes
verbatim how you doing goes I know what
you do I know you work I love your stuff
yeah your greatest specialist great
listen to me can I ask you a question he
goes anybody [__] with you at this party
tonight
[Laughter]
and was dead and I go what he goes
anybody [__] with you did anybody treat
you all right and I was like yeah I'm
fine I'm fine like why would you right
I'm just looking just to be like what
like First of all of course not right
right right we're at a corporate
but it was history but what I realized
was it was no it was his way of saying I
got you even though like because it's
not it doesn't need to go to violence
right right like you don't have to
there's no reason for it you just say
hey man by the way that guy manages a
7-Eleven yeah it's like every Italian
guy talks like I'm connected and you're
like you know then you find out you
probably deliver sodas for Mountain Dew
or whatever yeah cause what would have
happened what would have happened if I
was like yeah some guy in the bathroom
was an [__]
let's go who was it who was it that's
right made you're like yeah what are you
doing what are you gonna do yeah I know
the company you work for yeah that's so
how do women walk up with a card right
in the middle of the show dead middle
I'm in the middle of a joke she goes hey
I go
so I take the car and I'm like what are
you doing I'm like I'm in the middle of
a show like you can't walk up in the
middle thousand people here and she's
like like ah you know whatever and she's
talking I'm like you have to go back to
your seat so then she handed me a card
so I looked at a whole audience I'm like
should I open this card and read it
right now and they go nuts right so I
open the card no and she goes back there
and I go to read it and the first thing
is Sal it's something very similar to
this like I say open up I think I'm
gonna have a good you know Sal you are
like an angel Sent From Heaven and then
a whole place just goes ah and I'm like
oh you [__] me laughing I'm like all
right and I put the card away I was like
that's very sweet but you don't do that
there was a letter inside the card oh
boy then I read when I got home that was
extremely serious and tragic inside
cancer experience she had no no I I
don't want to say okay well no one uh it
was serious stuff I'll tell you and she
must have [__] herself because I would I
said I'm gonna read the car it was like
some really crazy [__] in there oh and
uh she must have been like oh my God
he's gonna read them when I got home I
realized she probably thought that and
it was like really sad inside and I'm
like I don't know now what do I do like
this woman calls me an angel she tells
me but she's still getting up in the
middle of a show I put the revolver in
my mouth but then episode 10 came on
yeah oh lady and she was very guys she
was very nice I'm not trashing you
because I know you watch this podcast
but a lady came on Saturday and and she
came up at the meet and greet and she
gave me a doll of Rosie O'Donnell
and she goes can you bring this to kill
you and I go oh yeah that's and she goes
but first she goes she goes that look
familiar and I go no
and she goes come on come on and I go I
don't know what I know it's a Rosie
O'Donnell I don't understand she goes
it's from the episode and I go
I've been practical jokers she goes yeah
I go I don't watch the show
it's so funny 300 episodes that you
wouldn't even know what she's talking
about and then she got kind of like she
said what do you mean you don't watch it
and I was like I have watched it and I
was like I don't know every bit every I
don't know what this is she's like it's
cute and I was like that's nice he's a
he's a friend of mine and uh and she
goes I want you to bring this to him and
I go
no
I'm not doing that and she goes
my friend went to high school with Joe
Gatto and I go lady I don't give a [__]
right and enjoy you're a one one degree
yeah and I go I go one degree like six
degrees even you know what I mean like I
go I go lady I don't give a [__] and she
goes oh and I go listen I'm [__] with
you a little bit here it's that's that's
nice but I go I can't bring this
and again she was very nice but she was
very kind of like come on come on come
on and Caitlin Reese who was opening for
me she just goes the lady goes I like
Caitlyn Caitlyn's great yeah and the
lady goes I paid 45 to see you and that
included this meet and greet Caitlyn
goes yeah well the meet and greet
doesn't come with a UPS delivery and the
lady was kind of like okay
nice and put it back and I was like
after the fact that I was like thank you
for like yeah you kind of got my back
there because it was like because I said
to her I go Caitlin was I a Dick friend
and she was like no no
it's almost it's almost disrespectful to
you in a way you know and not not enough
it's not a malicious purpose thing but
like they do like I had a I had uh Pete
Davidson on my podcast since these like
some of his fans were like why is like
Paul talking and it was like it's my
he's it's my show and but in their mind
in their mind they just want to hear
what Pete has to say yeah but they'll
they'll come up or like they'll be like
hey do you know him can you tell one
like some one girl wrote like listen I
think if like he really needs someone in
his life I could I could be there I
think there are things that I know I
could do and I'm going like are you are
you at it it's a thing I don't like and
it's happened to me
um
it it started when I used to do a bunch
of stuff with Burr all the time right
you know and you've probably been
through this with bird too where people
will be like hey Bill do you think you
could get built you know what I mean
yeah like like I haven't and you're like
dude um yeah I don't know I guess I
could you know whatever yeah like now
and it's funny though with this with
this show like this is this is the best
I I do not say this to bust your balls
in any way but when it first started it
was certainly yeah it was certainly way
more like people being like so Sal you
know like yeah
right yeah but now 90 of the people that
come up to me at my shows are like bro I
gotta tell you
I [__] think you're right all you
know what I mean yeah and I'm like you
thought everybody was gonna always be
sandbagging you yeah and I'm like no
just
what it really excites me is the taste
buds fans coming up and being like bro I
love how [__] dark the ACT is and I'm
like thank God because I was terrified
you people would be mad that I wasn't
talking about Donuts they're like no
dude we like it and I'm like so that's
been a really rewarding like shift but
um but yeah like people are like you
know yeah like I have an open for bill
now in about five and a half years and a
lot so much of that it stopped like
we'll do football picks together and
stuff and we'll do like you know
podcasts here and there because he's on
the west coast I'm on the East Coast but
compared to when I was working with him
a lot and opening for him it was like
what Joe said somebody like hey do you
think you could do this or would you do
this or like what do you do and I'm like
dude I'm not is it talk to the agency
you know and now that I don't like now
it's just like hey man I saw your
special I understand why Burr liked you
I like your stuff and like because you
have to do that you can't you can't
knock it just one thing too I get give
this to Q right well well that's the
thing and that's the thing I'm not again
I'm not knocking the very nice lady that
brought the doll in and all closer to
it's also I'm also not knocking when
like people will send stuff to the bar
and say like this is for you and South
that's different that's not what I mean
but there are people that if they know
you know somebody else
will be like do you think you could X Y
and Z for me and you're kind of like
well
and sometimes you're like dude I don't
even I'm not even resentful of what
you're asking it's just not appropriate
and the length of time it would take for
me to try to explain that is going to
make this conversation so awkward right
yeah sometimes that's like it's you know
the ask is even insane like people like
dude I dm'd you like I don't know the
person right be like dude I dm'd you
listen I need to talk to gato I'm like
wait what is going on here I was
supposed to catch that message and now
put you in touch with him this is insane
you know what I get a lot I get ah
we're the guys
I'm like I'm like back at home and I'll
bunk beds they have a life
The Three Stooges sleep with those with
those small caps I live by my I'm My Own
human where are we at on time pip
all right why don't we do this as a
two-parter why don't we just stop it and
do an episode of Comedy stories and then
and then let's do battle on the next one
and we just got we had a three episode
day baby
oh well I don't know if you have someone
to go no no I'm good what did you double
it up yeah what time is it it's 5 44.
can I plug my [__] oh 100 wait when does
this come out okay and then the next one
is going to be after that yeah right
after it 13 the week five well okay in
in theory in theory this one will
definitely come out on the sixth
there's a slight chance the second one
you're in might
get pushed back if we end up recording
okay no no because we do that either way
you have to but just sometimes we do it
that way but but yeah but probably not
like probably not that's all [__] right
now but then yeah yeah but I'm not so
this is not going to hit I'm at Gotham
on the second and third so this is going
to be so I'll be uh all right so I'll
just do a plug Pittsburgh then yeah baby
all right yeah so uh check me out I'll
be at the Pittsburgh improv uh
Valentine's Day so bring your dates into
Tuesday night doing a one-nighter and uh
it's almost filled up it's almost sold
out so get tickets to that and I have a
bunch of dates coming up um I'm gonna be
in Tampa I'm gonna be at the Vulcan in
Austin I'm going to be in Rhode Island
I'm gonna be in Salt Lake City Denver
just got Charlotte and Raleigh and go to
Paul verzi.com for all that stuff check
out the special on Netflix nocturnal
admissions too all right we're turning
this episode into a two-parter okay so
55 minutes yeah we're at 55 minutes so
that was a lot of fun and then we'll
take the battle into the next episode
The Next Episode will be Indian food
versus Chinese food I'm excited and I by
the way and I'm gonna say it now to
tease it for next week I want to do a
salty with version because and also
another tease with the next week's
episode it's the first time we've ever
done this Sal is going to moderate yeah
the battle I think I might have done it
once but okay with me versus the guest
yeah I'm gonna just be playing I'm just
gonna be moderating okay I'll tell you
so we have two chants that we do it
involves my ball set we have two chants
that we do at first he thought that we
would arguing too much and maybe taking
the hate home with us and so we came in
one day and he said before we start
let's look at each other in the eyes and
say no matter what happens I love you no
matter what happens I love you no matter
what happens I love you and then we used
to do that chant to go into and then it
would it did work where we wouldn't get
as vicious with each other okay but
before that we would say is it before
before that no no no oh after salty came
after me because that chant got us too
lovingly loving with each other we
weren't arguing them we weren't argued
enough so I started a chant call it's
time to get salty it's time to get salty
it's not get salty and as soon as you
stop saying it three times you fire an
insult right at the guy and it worked
before we start battling so I want to do
a salty with you in our battles I've
known you long enough that I think it'd
be fun to shoot a dish at each other
yeah yeah and so there's no [__]
nicely [__] let's get a nice fast
okay okay okay fair so yeah so just
think of this as a nice supersized
episode for you guys and Indian food
versus Chinese food will be next uh next
week
spots they come into the mic talking
about the food they hate talking about
the food they like two Fool's gonna
fight but only one food can be right
taste buds man yeah they're coming to
the mic